When we used our
energy principle,
suppose we have an object
that starts at a height h0.
And this object is dropped,
and when it gets to the ground,
it has some final velocity.
And when we applied
our energy principle,
assuming that there was
no air resistance, what
we saw was that the change in
kinetic energy plus the change
of potential energy was 0, so
we had 0 was equal to delta
k plus delta u.
And we saw that
the kinetic energy
changed by 1/2 mv squared, and
the potential energy changed
by minus mg h0.
So we can compute the
velocity of the object
as it's falling given
by square root of 2g h0.
Now that we're considering
kinetic energy of rotation,
recall that we show
that the kinetic energy
of a pure rotation
about a fixed axis
was 1/2 the moment
of inertia about
that axis times the
angular speed squared.
We now would like to
apply our energy principle
to include rotational
kinetic energy along
with the translational
kinetic energy.
And the example that
we want to look at
is something very simple.
Suppose we have a pulley.
Now our pulley has
a mass p, and we'll
say it has a moment of inertia
of the pulley about the fixed
axis passing through the
center of the pulley.
And we have a mass 1
and another block 2.
And let's suppose that
we release this system.
And for the moment let's make
this surface frictionless.
And suppose that block 2
falls down a certain distance.
So in the final
state, block 2 will
have dropped a
distance each final
from its initial position.
And what we like
to consider is find
the velocity final of block 2.
So we begin in the same way
that we've done this before,
by considering our
energy diagrams.
And so we'll have
an initial state.
And in our initial
state, what we'll do
is we'll just have
the initial 1, 2.
And I'm going to choose u
equals 0, here's my pulley.
And everything is at rest.
And so in the initial
state, the initial energy, i
initial, k initial,
plus u initial is 0.
And in our final state,
we have the pulley
is rotating with omega final.
Block 1 is moving with
a velocity v final 1.
And block 2 is also
moving with v2 final.
And let's just suppose that this
was our u equals 0 position.
And although it's not so
clear in the diagram, u final,
it has moved down
to height h final.
So what is the energy
in our final state?
Well, we have to consider
all the different pieces.
We have block 1, 1/2
m1, v1 final squared.
We have the motion of block
2, 1/2 m2 v2 final squared.
And we also have
the kinetic energy
of the pulley, which is given
by 1/2 I about the pulley
omega final squared.
And what about our
final potential energy?
Well, we've dropped
the height, h final.
So we have block 2 has
moved minus m2 gh final.
And now we have our
two energy states.
And what we'd like to consider
is apply the energy principle
just like we applied it
for this simple case.
But before we do that, there
is a constraint condition
that because the rope is fixed
in length, as block 1 moves,
the pulley is rotating
and block 2 is moving.
What we'll have is
fixed and not slipping.
So as the rope moves
around the pulley,
the pulley is moving with
the same motion as the rope,
and the rope is moving with
the speeds of block 1 and 2,
so we see that v1 final
is equal to v2 final.
And now what about the pulley?
If this is radius r, we
know that the velocity
of a point on the
rim of a disk is
moving with the speed
of the rope, which
is the speed of
block 1 and block 2,
So that's our omega final.
And so that makes our final
energy, let's now gather terms.
The velocities are the same.
So we have 1/2 and 1 plus m2.
And we'll just call this
the final for simplicity.
1/2 m2 times v final squared.
That accounts for
these two terms.
And we have the moment of
inertia, kinetic energy
associated with the wheel, which
is 1/2i omega final squared,
which is v final squared over
r squared minus m2 gh final.
And so now we can solve
our energy principle, which
is because we're assuming
everything's frictionless,
we have 0 equals E
final minus E initial,
implies that E final
equals E initial.
And we chose our initial
potential energy to be 0.
So of course that's just
a choice of constant.
So I can now solve this equation
by setting E final equal to 0.
That's the same statement.
And then you can
see algebraically I
can solve for V final.
And what I get is I'm just going
to write all these terms over.
I get m2gh final.
I'm going to divide by this
common coefficient, 1/2 and 1
plus m2 plus the
moment of inertia
divided by radius squared.
And I now have to take the
square root of the whole thing.
And that's how I can find
the velocity of block 2
when it's dropped down a
certain distance to h final.
So here we've generalized
our energy approach
to include rotational
kinetic energy.